Narrator: The new trailer
for "Detective Pikachu"
is full of recognizable Pokémon
from the classic series,
and you have to look carefully
if you wanna catch them all.
Here's a look at everything
you might have missed.
The film stars Ryan Reynolds as Pikachu,
And is this a subtle reference
to another Ryan Reynolds
character, Green Lantern?
Pikachu: Another round, extra shot,
blackest night, thank you sweetie.
Narrator: "Blackest Night" is the name
of a "Green Lantern" comic series.
The movie takes place in
the fictional Ryme City,
the same city in the Nintendo 3DS game,
and the plot revolves around Pikachu
and a boy named Tim Goodman
searching for his father Harry Goodman,
who disappeared after
a mysterious car crash.
Kathryn Newton from "Big Little Lies"
plays a character named Lucy,
seen here with her Psyduck.
The shots of Ryme City
are full of references
to various Pokémon from
different generations.
Here's a Snorlax sleeping
at an intersection,
a shout-out to the games
in which the Snorlax
usually blocks the player's path.
Machamp seems to be directing traffic
with his multiple arms.
Outside the RCPD building,
we see multiple police dogs,
Growlithe and the evolved form Arcanine.
There's also what appears to be a Slaking
lying in the background,
and Gen V's Golurk working
as security guards.
Climbing on the power lines
outside of this building
are some Joltik, bug-electric-type
Pokémon from Gen V.
In the game, the Hi-Hat Café
is owned by a character
named Pablo Millan,
and his Pokémon Ludicolo seen here.
Ludicolo: Ludicolo!
Narrator: The sign outside
the café shows the owl Pokémon
Noctowl, which makes sense
since it's a nocturnal creature.
We see a very furry Jigglypuff
on the table in the café,
which also appeared in the first trailer.
And behind it is a poster
for an upcoming battle
between two fighting-type Pokémon.
Machamp and Primeape.
Mr. Mime was also featured
in the first trailer
with his disturbing new look,
and he's still being
interrogated by Tim and Pikachu.
We also see some quick shots
of a slobbery Lickitung
and a grumpy looking Snubull.
The trailer give us our first glimpse
of a Pokémon battle arena as well.
Flanking the DJs are two Loudred Pokémon,
which have ears that
work like loudspeakers.
The two Pokémon fighting
appear to be Blastoise
and the ghost-type Pokémon Gengar.
And if you look closely,
there's even a Magikarp
in the fish tank in the background.
We get a quick shot of many other Pokémon,
watching from the sidelines.
Behind Pikachu is Pancham,
a panda-like Pokémon
we also saw on a missing persons poster
next to a missing Squirtle.
There's also a Charmander and a Treecko.
And in the wide shot, we
see what appears to be
Audino and Octillery.
Pikachu gets paired up against Charizard,
whose trainer also has a
Charizard tattoo on his chest.
There's a brief shot of a
large building in a valley,
this is likely the Pokémon
Comprehensive Laboratory
from the video game,
a key location in the plot of the story,
which we won't spoil here.
Here we see Tim and Pikachu
being led through a stream
by a bunch of Bulbasaur and Morelull.
And a Cubone, which wears
the skull of its dead mother,
pops out of a Pokéball.
There are a few different shots
of a monkey fighting-type
Pokémon called Aipom,
which look a lot more vicious
than they do in the games or cartoon.
On the desk next to Pikachu,
we see three stones.
These are likely evolution stones,
which are used to evolve certain Pokémon.
The one in the middle
resembles the Sinnoh Stone,
a Gen IV stone exclusive to Pokémon Go.
Speaking of evolutions,
the trailer also shows us an Eevee
evolving into a fire-type
Pokémon, Flareon.
And behind this Flareon are statues
of Dialga, Arceus, and Palkia
from left to right.
Ryme City is famous for
hosting a Pokémon carnival,
and these parade balloons
likely appear during this event.
We get our first look at
the legendary Gen I Pokémon
Mewtwo emerging from
one of these balloons.
Mewtwo also plays a very important role
in the story, but you'll have to wait
until the film comes out in
May to solve the mystery.
Tim: He's barely moving.
Pikachu: Don't tell him that.
Oh, he's on a bike, quick,
get in front of him.
Tim: Stop.
Pikachu: Oh no, he's going down hard, Tim.
Shoulda worn a helmet.